what are the different structures for
television
television
usually exists as half hours
hours
and
limited series
within that
there's some flexibility
the half hour form which used to be
limited to sitcoms and really isn't
anymore
really only runs 20 22 minutes it's very
short
but how is that divided well
some people used to say the comedy
structure
was uh
you know three beats up three beats down
with a whoops in the middle
i don't think that holds any more uh
there are
comedies that are in three act structure
standard three x structure they're
comedies that are in four rack structure
there are comedies
that are what the heck is going on here
and um
and they can all work
because they're uh propelled by the
characters and the kind of material and
the kind of humor if there is humor half
hours are also not only comedy uh more
half hours or dramedy now or what you
might call as uh simply half hour dramas
and that's different also if you look at
something like atlanta
uh which is not bound by uh
legacy structure that it has to fit
within a half hour plus ads which brings
it down to like a 20-minute show you
might have a 40-minute episode and hbo
is perfectly happy to have that happen
up coming away from comedy which is not
my specialty uh
ours
are
depends where you look um an hour might
be more than an hour
uh on uh
on hbo
or might be a full hour and even a
little more on hbo or netflix
or even amazon
um
it might be much less than it might be
on legacy television it's 40 some odd
minutes
because they're allowing for the
commercials so it varies and then the
limited series uh are all different if
you look at something like um
eva de barnes uh when you see us
that's six hours
uh brilliant six hours most of those
hours are one hour long but sometimes
i think one of them if i recall the
beginning one was two hours long
and you often see that in the
in the um
i don't want to say miniseries in the
limited series you'll also often find
that one of those hours is a two-hour
segment
they call it special
it's also called as you know finishing
the show
um
but are they an hour long yeah mostly
kinda mostly kind of they have to fit on
the schedule
game of thrones was often not an hour it
was more
a handmaid's tale is less
because on hulu it shows with
commercials
so
if you're if you're working on a show
you have to look at that show and see
how they work
and then better call saul
you said it called amc and amc has
commercials and uh
it could certainly it certainly has the
depth
uh to go for an hour but it doesn't it
runs more like 50 minutes
what's the difference between a five act
and a six act structure
well i first of all don't really believe
in acts structures so much anymore i i
really like to look at the forex
structure as a
basis and the five act structure is a
forex structure with the fourth act
divided in half a sixth acts
sometimes is those buybacks and then you
add a tag which is some extra material
but there's also another way of doing it
which is that every act is a little
shorter
i don't
i don't recommend anybody writing a spec
episode in six acts
i really think that if somebody out
there is watching this in order to learn
how to write a sample a spec sample
script which is required by many of the
fellowships
that you should really go with the four
act plus teaser or no wax at all
the six-ax structure is clumsy
because it keeps breaking first of all
and then also the reader anticipates
it's going to be ending and then oh wait
a minute here's another piece
so i i don't think anybody should do
that
and so for a first-time spec writer uh
submitting something should they stick
to an hour
well yeah if they're doing drama they
have to stick to another you have to
okay i mean if you're a comedy writer
that's different
uh then uh clearly you will write a
comedy uh sample
and that's that's another world all
together this
if it's uh
if it's
taped i mean if it's multi-cam
not too many people are doing that
anymore
but if it's a multi-cam sitcom in the
old fashioned sense
it's probably going to be
in a different page format as well you
have to look you'll look that up
whereas
dramatic scripts and
live action filmed
comedies look like feature films
can you explain a b and c stories
uh a b and c stories are parallel
stories that are not subplots
in dramatic shows especially
you will have
major
full
plots
that are linked to
uh primary characters
the a story generally has more beats the
b story may have the same number beats
or fewer and the c stories sometimes a
runner um it's just a way of thinking
about storytelling uh when you have
the kinds of narrative
that lap over from episode to episode so
you might have an a story
in
episode five
which is actually continues in episode
six as a b story
and comes back to being an a story in
episode seven and you might have it
weaving so the b story which is also
very important but not the prominent one
in episode five really has a major turn
in episode six so
you're you're weaving throughout the
season
as well as weaving within your episode
that isn't to say the episode can't
stand alone because it should
but
that's that's what parallel storytelling
is
it's just multiple narratives they are
not subplots to each other they are full
stories
could we try using that with an example
of something maybe better call saul
better call saul might have jimmy saul
as the a story
kim his wife
might have a separate arc in that show
even though she also intersects with him
but there also might be a story for
nacho
which
doesn't even include saul or kim and
takes place at a different it takes
place in mexico is in a different place
a different time
uh well at the same time usually but a
different location with different
characters
uh they all impact each other and
there's usually a thematic link but
they're actually
separate stories in themselves
if you look at the precursor breaking
bad walter white
will have a story
would uh jessie
have a separate story with different
characters
maybe maybe
um
walter's
in breaking bad walter white really was
the dominant person
but there were
there are other characters who might
have scenes that he isn't in
and might have a number of beats that
tell whatever their arc is for that show
how do you stretch out an idea over
multiple
episodes without it feeling too drawn
out you never stretch an idea
there is no such thing as an idea that
stretches there's only a story that
needs to be told
if you find
that your material is too short
that the story you have
does not last for an hour or for
whatever length of time
you need to think about your story and
who these people are and what more needs
to be told
never stretch and never shrink
i've seen people
i've seen students do things that are
just silly
which is
to work with the final draft to make
more space between letters to make it
look bigger or take out space to make a
that doesn't fool anybody plus it won't
work because when you actually make the
show it's going to be the length it is
so that's silly
if you find that you don't actually have
enough story
you can do a few things one is
go back into your characters and ask are
there layers of this character that i
have not yet examined
go back into your secondary characters
and say is there more to them are they
too superficial do they have arcs or
stories in themselves that could become
a b story
uh is there a different place to end my
story am i if it's too short
have i stopped before it
really concluded or
more likely have i failed to develop the
middle
uh
generally
people who
are lacking material are lacking it in
the middle they think they're lacking it
at the end and they need to go on
and that's never that that's rarely the
truth
sometimes
i have found
early scripts
that don't start in the right place
the general notion is to start as close
to the action as possible so you want to
start as late as possible
but
there are a number of instances where
you really need to know
what led what caused this story and they
needed to back up and add
essentially a whole act
for what happened before or what
propelled the character so they're
missing something
never stretch never never fool with it
the idea and the story tells itself
so a better problem to have is how can i
condense this
you might say a better problem is how to
condense it if you need to hit an hour
if you need to hit 60 minutes
and if if it's running too long
there are a few things you can look at
the simplest is are your dialogue speech
is too long
and that's a common error
that
people are just simply over talking
that
they say uh
play it don't say it and is this
something we can see visually instead of
explaining it uh or that you've got
exposition that needs to go because it's
obvious anyway on screen
or because um
you have uh indulged in uh directing on
the page or set decoration so there's
just simply too much writing that isn't
part of telling the story so that's an
editing thing
often editing won't um
if you're way long it it won't cut
enough pages i mean if you're up at
uh 75 pages for something that should be
60 pages
editing might not get you there
what may be happening in that case
is that
you've actually strayed
from the focus of your story or that you
even have a whole other character or a
whole of a story storyline that needs to
be in a new episode
so those those are things you can do if
you're running long
um
in general or
sometimes
that um your script was really over and
you went on
but you'd have to look at it case by
case
uh
there is
unless you're aaron sorkin and you're
writing something that's
normally 70 pages because it's so
dialogue rich
that it's running it's 6 70 pages are
going to run 60 minutes
but unless you're doing that
and you shouldn't be doing that
you should get you should tighten your
script to what works within an hour
but if you're if your first
uh inclination is how do i stretch this
out then you know that maybe go back to
what your your whole idea is even about
because it sounds like there needs to be
if your question is how do i stretch
this out you're asking the wrong
question
um
and you need to go all the way back to
who you are as a writer
and what is the thing you have to tell
you